[Música]
diplomacia para intentar solucionar la
crisis fronteriza en ucrania / ante la
presión militar de rusia el ministro de
exteriores ruso recomendó continuar las
negociaciones mientras que la onu pide
reducir la especulación
la idea emergencia en canadá el primer
ministro georges crudo invocó el poder
para enfrentar las protestas del llamado
convoy de la libertad esto le permitiría
declarar como ilegales las
manifestaciones contra la vacunación del
cob y 19
y méxico denuncia intereses políticos
detrás de la suspensión de exportación
de aguacates a eeuu el presidente de
andrés manuel lópez obrador así lo
denuncio aunque no dio más detalles
washington como la medida luego de que
un inspector estadounidense fuera
amenazado
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes y comenzamos
esta emisión en europa del este moscú y
occidente aún le apuestan a la
diplomacia para desescalar las tensiones
en la frontera entre rusia y ucrania hoy
el ministro de relaciones exteriores
ruso serguéi lávrov le recomendó al
mandatario vladimir putin continuar con
las negociaciones pues afirmó que hay
posibilidad de lograr un acuerdo sobre
la seguridad mientras que el mandatario
ucraniano volodymyr selenski le pidió a
quienes han abandonado su país que
regresen justo el mismo día que eeuu
clausuró su embajada en kiev para mover
sus operaciones a la ciudad de leópolis
más cerca a polonia por su parte del
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres se mostró preocupado por lo que
llamó la especulación
estoy profundamente preocupado por el
aumento de las tensiones y el aumento de
la especulación sobre un posible
conflicto militar en europa el precio es
sufrimiento humano destrucción y daño a
la seguridad europea y mundial es
demasiado alto para contemplarlo
security is tú a tú con templates vean
during diplomacy for confrontation es
abandonar la diplomacia por la
confrontación no es cruzar una línea es
lanzarse al precipicio en resumen mi
llamado es este no fracasar la causa de
la paz donuts fail 23 peace otra de las
movidas diplomáticas para intentar desde
escalar las tensiones entre rusia y
occidente fue la visita del canciller
alemán olaf scholz a kiev allí se reunió
con el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
volodymyr se le skin y adoptó un tono
más fuerte contra el kremlin
advirtiéndole que cualquier agresión
tendría graves consecuencias shows
viajará mañana a rusia para avanzar en
la diplomacia
un desfile de diplomáticos con el
característico apretón de manos que
busca evitar lo peor
olaf scholz es el último líder europeo
en dirigirse tanto a ucrania como rusia
en un intento de calmar las tensiones
poco después de aterrizar en kiev el
canciller alemán reiteró su apoyo a su
homólogo ucraniano volodymyr selenski y
expresó a moscú sus exigencias de imagen
que no hay más vuelvo dejar claro a
quien quiera que la soberanía y la
integridad territorial de ucrania no son
negociables para alemania por tanto
esperamos que rusia dé pasos claros para
escalar las tensiones actuales 7 saudíes
colección the game that in spain
sol sigue los pasos del presidente
francés emmanuel macro no mientras los
líderes europeos se unen tras el temor a
una inminente invasión de ucrania rusia
ha acumulado a más de 130 mil soldados
en la frontera del país y las fuerzas de
la otan están preparando su respuesta a
ese poderío militar con una expedición
de soldados alemanes que aterrizó en
lituania el lunes y el envío de más
aviones de combate f-15 a polonia por
parte de eeuu
reino unido también está dispuesto a
aumentar sus tropas de la otan en
estonia aunque el primer ministro boris
johnson dijo que todavía espera que se
pueda evitar el conflicto
esta es una situación muy muy peligrosa
y difícil estamos al borde del
precipicio pero aún hay tiempo para que
el presidente putin dé un paso atrás y
lo que pedimos es que todos dialoguen
una propuesta también se está
considerando en moscú según una reunión
televisada entre vladimir putin y
sérguei lávrov el ministro de exteriores
ruso dijo que todavía hay una
posibilidad de resolución diplomática
con occidente y nuestras opciones están
lejos de agotarse pero las
conversaciones no deben continuar
indefinidamente pero en este momento yo
sugeriría que continuaremos las
conversaciones y les ampliaremos
moscú sostiene que no tiene planes de
invadir ucrania a pesar de la
preocupación internacional sin embargo
en lo que respecta a la diplomacia
muchos siguen temiendo que las
conversaciones fracasen en un tema clave
el ingreso de ucrania a la otan es al
que rusia se opone rotundamente
ley de emergencia en canadá el primer
ministro georges team trudeau advirtió
que será limitado y en ciertas
provincias el mandatario invocó hoy ese
poder para hacerle frente a las
manifestaciones de los transportistas
que rechazan la vacunación contra el
kobe 19 y que han bloqueado vías desde
hace dos semanas la declaración le
permitirá al gobierno federal declarar
ilegal las protestas y autorizaría a
mover con remolques los vehículos que
bloqueen las vías esta es la respuesta
de true dom a la que ha sido la presión
política más alta que ha enfrentado
durante su mandato paralelamente la
provincia de ontario levantará el pase
de vacuna a partir del primero de marzo
aunque afirman que no son por las
protestas sino porque los casos de kobe
19 han disminuido escuchemos lo que dijo
crudo
la ley de emergencia será usada para
fortalecer y apoyar a las fuerzas del
orden en todo nivel a lo largo del país
eso es para proteger la seguridad de los
canadienses proteger los empleos y
restaurar la confianza en nuestras
instituciones
y aunque las protestas por el
coronavirus se están disminuyendo en
canadá con la reapertura del paso
fronterizo clave con eeuu
la idea del convoy de la libertad que
empezó en este país ya se ha extendido
por todo el mundo y es que ha habido
manifestaciones similares en países como
francia nueva zelanda y ahora en israel
en el siguiente informe hacemos un
recuento al trasfondo de este rechazo
alambre de púas y barricadas protegen la
comisión europea un mensaje claro para
los manifestantes no son bienvenidos las
autoridades belgas prohibieron el
bloqueo de bruselas y advirtieron en
contra de cualquier intento de
introducir en la ciudad un convoy de la
libertad al estilo de canadá la policía
estaba canalizando los vehículos hacia
las afueras donde sólo se permitía un
plantón contra las restricciones
impuestas por la pandemia
te pedimos libertad que se detenga la
vacuna o el pase sanitario y que no
obliguen a la gente a vacunarse muchos
manifestantes habían viajado desde
francia que a su vez estuvieron en parís
durante el fin de semana la policía
impidió en gran medida que los
conductores accedieron a la ciudad un
centenar de vehículos entró a la avenida
de los campos elíseos o enfrentamientos
y decenas fueron detenidos a pesar de
que el gobierno apunta a planes para
relajar los mandatos de las mascarillas
a finales de mes e incluso la esperanza
de detener el proyecto de su pase de
vacunas para marzo o abril los
manifestantes se inspiran en una
caravana similar en canadá una que
paralizó la capital del país durante
tres semanas y que bloqueó tres pasos
fronterizos clave que unen con eeuu por
el puente a buster en ontario cruza una
cuarta parte de todo el comercio entre
ambos países su reapertura se logró el
fin de semana para el alivio de las
autoridades la policía ha tratado de
manejar esto de una manera mesurada no
ha habido violencia y lo agradecemos
mucho ese era el objetivo desde el
principio aún así la ira generada por
las restricciones por el coronavirus se
mantiene otros países como nueva zelanda
australia países bajos e israel han
visto como movimientos similares cada
vez toman más fuerza ahora nos movemos
un poco más al sur del continente porque
en méxico aumentan las tensiones luego
de que estados unidos suspendiera la
importación de aguacates desde ese país
hoy el mandatario mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador dijo que detrás de la
medida había muchos intereses sus
políticos aunque no explicó cuáles y
defendió que además méxico sigue
exportando este producto a diferentes
países washington suspendió la las
importaciones el sábado un día antes del
super bowl que es la mayor oportunidad
de ventas para los productores mexicanos
la prohibición fue porque amenazaron a
un inspector de seguridad estadounidense
en los campos mexicanos de aguacates
escuchemos lo que dijo andrés manuel
lópez obrador
hay también muchos intereses
económicos
políticos hay competencia
no quisieran que
el aguacate mexicano no
entrar a eeuu predominará
por su calidad hay otros países
interesados en vender el aguacate a
propósito de méxico este es uno de los
países más peligrosos para ejercer el
periodismo en el mundo así lo demuestran
las cifras porque en las últimas dos
décadas los reporteros asesinados suman
150 este año 2022 comenzó con una ola de
violencia contra la prensa con el
asesinato de al menos cinco reporteros
es el recrudecimiento de un fenómeno que
no es nuevo y que ha obligado a
periodistas al desplazamiento forzoso
nuestro corresponsal mario carbonell
tiene la historia desde ciudad de mexico
veamos este informe
la periodista cynthia valdez sufrió
amenazas de muerte de un grupo criminal
en su estado natal sinaloa el mecanismo
del gobierno de protección para
periodistas la traslado a ciudad de
méxico y le dio refugio tres años
después ella decidió volver a su lugar
de origen a ejercer nuevamente su labor
a pesar de sentir que las autoridades la
abandonaron en este proceso se
estableció un plan de retorno en
conjunto con la ciudad pero sin embargo
hasta la fecha no se ha acordado ninguna
medida me dejaron en la total
indefensión al perder yo mis medidas de
seguridad porque ni siquiera tengo un
monitoreo ya de policía federal ni de
ninguna institución de seguridad en
sinaloa aula saucedo de artículo 19
advierte que las medidas del gobierno
para proteger a periodistas en peligro
se limitan a un enfoque reactivo que no
hay prevención en las medidas que se dan
yo te doy una medida de protección pero
que al yo no investigar estas amenazas
de dónde vienen no generarte condiciones
para para aumentar los costos de que te
agredan te van a seguir agrediendo un
mar bello es otro periodista en riesgo
que debió abandonar su natal guerrero
tras ser víctima de secuestro y amenazas
lleva cuatro años en un refugio en
ciudad de méxico y su única medida de
protección es un botón de pánico
esto nada más para que sepan dónde
quedaste
realmente de que aquello le apachurro
aquí el botón y se dan cuenta ya me
mataron
al sufrir la agresión tenía ocho años
trabajando de manera formal en un
periódico de zihuatanejo hoy no logra
conseguir empleo y una de las
consecuencias de ser desplazado y de
estar bajo el mecanismo es que pierdes
entre otras cosas tu vida laboral
cintia y omar tuvieron la fortuna de ser
protegidos a tiempo la misma suerte no
la tuvieron los cinco periodistas
asesinados entre el 15 de enero y el 10
de febrero de 2022 con lo que ya suman
29 en el sexenio actual el 90 por ciento
de los crímenes contra periodistas en el
país quedan impunes entró en vigor la
nueva ley de migración y extranjería en
chile la norma permitirá hacer
devoluciones en caliente que es como se
conoce a las expulsiones inmediatas sin
que tengan un proceso judicial aunque el
texto de la ley asegura que busca
promover una migración regular y
ordenada la legislación entró en vigor
en 2021 pero todavía no había sido
aprobada el gobierno la promulgó este
fin de semana luego de las protestas de
los camioneros contra los migrantes este
lunes decenas de emigrantes bolivianos
fueron devueltos en la frontera en total
60 personas han sido deportadas las
personas no cumplen los requisitos no
había una necesidad protección por lo
tanto hoy en día siguen estando como
residentes en bolivia y si quieren
entrar a chile si tienen familia en
chile esperamos que soliciten su visa a
través de la plataforma disponible para
ello y si cumple los requisitos entre
con bis y con root pero el gobierno de
chile no aceptará más ingresos
clandestinos tensión política en perú el
presidente del consejo de ministros
aníbal torres acusó a un grupo de
congresistas de la oposición de planear
lo que llamó un golpe de estado a través
de la vacancia presidencial y a la vez
dijo que el gobierno de pedro castillo
está a la espera que el congreso
programe el voto de confianza y es que
los legisladores deben aprobar el
reciente gabinete que nombró el
presidente peruano el jefe de gobierno
anunció que se reunirá con todas las
bancadas
entablar un diálogo político
estas acciones son productos por
supuesto de un sector minoritario del
congreso acciones que como es señalado
atentan contra el estado de derecho
atentan contra la democracia contra la
gobernabilidad y tratan de desacreditar
al perú ante la comunidad internacional
y para terminar nuestro noticiero
hablemos del día de san valentín que se
celebra hoy como todos los 14 de febrero
para eso vamos a hacer un breve recuento
de cómo se celebró esta fecha en
distintos países y comenzamos en
tailandia donde 40 parejas aprovecharon
la festividad para casarse mientras
montaban en elefantes y hacían un
desfile aunque esta práctica de utilizar
a los elefantes ha sido denunciada por
grupos ambientalistas en ocasiones
anteriores en argentina los enamorados
celebraron su unión en un parque de
ensueño de buenos aires
repleto de rosas sin embargo un panorama
totalmente diferente se vivió en
afganistán donde el gobierno talibán
ordenó el cierre de mercados y la
destrucción de la decoración de san
valentín de san valentín y es que ellos
consideran esta festividad como
prohibida en la ley islámica del sharia
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que consulten nuestra
página web france24 puntocom ya que
sigan conectados a nuestra señal
[Música]